let's go a little esoteric sure you have
to we barely did at the beginning I
thought we were going to go all the way
down the path of extraterrestrial
intervention
um but telomeres you were talking about
obviously 250 years thousand years ago
is when we have a gene splice edit
something what seemed what I've heard is
sort of unexplainable we don't
understand why there is a splice in the
in the genetic coding
um and that uh that telomeres are capped
and is that something that appears to
have been done to us and then also is it
true that they're capped for us to live
to 120 years only up until literally a
couple years ago
the only uh thinking around telomeres
was here's your DNA right and remember
at the very beginning I was saying your
DNA getting damaged is a definition of
Aging that's that's what it is your
cells unravel your DNA gets damage and
you age so the telomeres are like
bumpers so they protect your DNA and so
telomeres have been a a marker for
biological age because the more worn
down they are Yeah the more you've
abused your DNA and that's how old you
actually are biologically right
but this is based on these various
algorithms and clocks that assume we can
get to 120. so if you look at our innate
biological function and structure we are
beings that are designed to live to 120
and those telometers mirrors are meant
to last until that age oh there's
there's two things why is there a cap
is is it is it to protect us which we
think it is or is it to cap us
which one which one is it because isn't
there stories in ancient history Bible
even where people live for several
hundred six seven eight hundred years
yeah every ancient tradition talks about
people living for centuries
right and we're seeing evidence of that
dummy you've spoken to plenty of people
that have evidence of that so what
happened is it that we have something
that we evolved into to protect our DNA
or since there was a magic edit was
there also a magic cap installed to
limit how how old are the how many years
our DNA can actually last so we in
science we're reacting to everything so
we found this thing and we say no it's a
bumper It's a protector and if we
measure it we know how old we are but if
we dig deeper and we start to look at
what we've learned historically there's
plenty of content that's not from 2023
that was from you know minus 20 to 250
000 right that tells us otherwise that
people did live longer it's too
coincidental that different people in
different parts of the world that never
spoke to each other all say the same
thing and it's not that we just live
longer they're very specific about the
like six to eight hundred years things
and they're from different parts of the
world at different times up until recent
history the res said recorded history
which is what you learn in school is
when this ends the story ends kind of
post Christ type history right
everything be before that is a blur to
us it's not a blur if you look at
ancient texts that are available we just
aren't taught it right and it's a very
different story if we look at stuff so
it's a question mark is this telomere
protective or is it a cap it seems like
it's both could those stories of Ben
off-planet extraterrestrial or hybrid
beings that did live six eight hundred
years but we this we as a homo sapien
sapien or whatever we are
um human being we only have ever lived a
certain amount of time which seems to be
much shorter is that that could be
possible too so if there was a
technology a quarter million years ago
that took a primate and edited two parts
of the genome
to make us who we are somebody with some
intelligence had to do that and it
wasn't us
exactly right it
that was not Evolution Evolution doesn't
happen in an edit it takes millions of
years
since that time we have not seen
evolution in ourselves
right so how did that happen overnight
that was a cause that was that was
intentional so I don't know if the
answer is
the Lord came down and edited us right
and created us is the answer that
there's another species from another
planet or from this planet that maybe is
still here somewhere that we don't know
about right so what but what's clear is
that the way we became Who We Are
was not the way every other species
became who they are it was not we didn't
not evolve into it we became it there
was a switch that was turned on that was
immediate and that was two edits to diff
two different parts of our genome that
are clear that no scientists can dispute
exist they just don't want to talk about
why it happened nobody's trying to
investigate why it happened what the
f is junk DNA
so junk DNA are sections of your genetic
code that have no information
which to me
in the Perfection of this human body the
complexity of this human body there's no
room for junk
right so it's just if you're programming
something and there's certain code that
you don't need anymore you turn it off
so at the time if we feel that there was
an edit who edited us I think you have
some theories there right
there was also junk and junk wasn't
added it it seems like there's the troll
sections of our DNA which we don't know
what they do because they're turned off
that are literally off so it's as if you
had a line of computer code and somebody
took a portion of it and censored it and
how can you see the difference between
deleted and censored because it's still
there is there a structure there's still
structure yeah it's structure it's yeah
what's the difference between DNA that
you can see versus the junk DNA that is
empty essentially what does it look like
tangibly so it isn't coded right so
there's there's letters that uh there's
four letters a b c t that make up your
genetic code and there's many many
combinations right each each gene is
thousands of letters long yeah right and
then so sometimes there's a c instead of
a t and now that Gene doesn't do its job
properly in a certain location so
there's no code in the junk it's it's
literal junk but how do you see the code
how do you even see a code oh so that's
sequencing so now we're getting into
when so I take your saliva which I did
yeah right and I extract your DNA from
the saliva there's a tool that does that
and we then put that DNA into a
sequencing machine which literally knows
how to read the code on every chromosome
and every so that that's how it's
literally red right by the sequencing
machine okay Illumina is the biggest
company that does that most companies
use alumina uh and when you're
sequencing it this section can't be read
there's nothing to read there's no code
so and and again
if there's nothing in this body that
isn't purposeful
right there's nothing that isn't
purposeful and something as precious and
you know a fundamental foundational
sorry as our genetic code right having
space spaces like empty spaces
there's there's a purpose there and the
purpose is either it used to exist and
it was turned off yeah
or we don't know how to turn it on right
well as you know from our friend Kaya
part of her book The Sophia code is
about
verbal initiations that activate dormant
DNA and that makes sense to me because
we talk about elevating Consciousness
we don't understand the science like the
Practical mechanism of what happens what
if you elevate Consciousness which means
you're now sending and receiving what
you couldn't send and received before
that means that those antennas or
whatever those things are are now
activated you didn't have access to them
prior to that so that could be that
maybe there's certain section our DNA
turn off to prevent us from accessing a
certain level of Consciousness that we
can fight and turn on I've experienced
this you've taught we've talked to you
about this you've experienced this in
the last two years I've experienced more
of this in the rest of my life combined
you know there's there's shifts
happening right now that if you're on
the right path you're going to
experience it for sure yeah uh and it's
there so it'd be interesting to see you
know I'm going to do this now now that
you said this I'm going to keep working
on elevating my Consciousness and I'm
going to re-sequence my ID and a to see
if something's changed that didn't exist
before Oh my God or can you see what
percentage of your body has active DNA
versus unread is there
right so if you're you're reading some
but some doesn't read so if you gave a
if you had a sample Can it can can it
evaluate a ratio
so every cell in your body is has DNA in
it so every single cell has active DNA
there's very little junk DNA it's micro
like little fragments here and there
that are junk yeah some junk in there um
all right you have a book what's the
book called so the book is called the
DNA way
and early on in this journey you know
when we built the company we were still
a research company at the time when
biotech is a weird place to be because
you learn and you don't even know why
you're learning it like what is what is
the product going to be it doesn't even
matter we're just researching and that's
where we were and so I realized as I was
doing this that we needed to normalize
DNA as a tool people don't even know
that it has to be part of your health
toolkit if you don't understand your
foundational code how do you make every
other decision you're gonna trial an
error one size fit all things until they
work
and so
um I found I was recommended this book
agent who represents ad best-selling
medical type authors and he said I love
your story you need to write a book I
agree with you and then he came back to
me after paying him for four or five
months and he said you got rejected by
every single publisher that exists
because you're not a doctor
and I said well I told you up front that
I'm not a doctor and I told you up front
that what I'm trying to fix is the
Health Care system and it takes somebody
from the outside to see what's what what
the blinders on what everybody can't see
right he said I'm sorry this isn't
working so I said give me the list of
who rejected us right and I said thank
you you know here's your check thank you
for your time I'll deal with this myself
so I I found of that list of Publishers
somebody who represented a few authors
that I like that I enjoy including Mindy
by the way right Mindy Pals uh and I
called them
and within three days I had a book deal
yeah and because they didn't I mean what
we do is so impactful but him as a guy
that represents 80 doctors thinks like
the doctors know he himself couldn't get
out of that medical thinking right like
so anyways so the the the intention was
the purpose of this book is for me to go
through my personal genome and show how
easy it is to use these tools and change
your life I've changed my life I've gone
from a 38 year old that was 43
biologically to a 43 year old that is 33
biologically
I'm the best shape of my life mentally
physically in every way even spiritually
my ability to connect is beyond what
it's ever been right uh and so I wanted
to share that with everybody because
whether you have a test or not there's
things to learn in terms of how does the
science work what can you do there's
things that you'll start to Clue Into
and you'll see the world differently
you'll see people differently because
you'll understand how your body actually
works
episode click at the bottom of your
screen